Hillary Clinton has surged to a 15 point
lead over Donald Trump in a recent poll
by McClatchy marist 48 2 33 and leads in
all 16 of the most recent polls let's
take a look at this and it is all blue
lewis everything from the recent ABC
news/washington post poll all the way
down the page 16 polls back to the
Economist yougov poll of a little over a
week ago it is blue Hillary Clinton up
from as little as one point all the way
up to 15 points as I mentioned in that
recent McClatchy marist poll also if you
include the up for way polling not
everybody does four-way polling so we
have fewer polls to look at we have that
data to show you Hillary Clinton up in
the recent 10-4 way polls which include
libertarian Gary Johnson and green party
candidate Jill Stein and the best part
about this is Donald Trump is no doubt
not nearly done saying insane and
ignorant things I can't wait for the
national debates personally uh the
McClatchy pol confirms similar numbers
to what we've been looking at in uh
other polls as far as Bernie supporters
last month eighty-three percent of
Bernie supporters were going to vote for
Hillary Clinton in November
self-reported that number has increased
to ninety percent this month in that
same poll and Donald Trump is also
hurting in here the same poll last month
70 I'm sorry eighty-five percent of
republicans were supporting Trump that
number is now down to 79 percent let's
look now at electoral dash vote dot-coms
prediction based on state-by-state
polling yikes this is getting really
really bad for Donald Trump according to
electoral dash vote dot-com Hillary
Clinton currently expecting 319
electoral votes on november eighth
needing only 270 to be the next
president of the United States Trump at
185 currently electoral vote calm has
only Ohio and Georgia estates that are
currently tied even giving every single
one of those electoral votes to Donald
Trump he would be nowhere close to where
he needs to be to be President of the
United States and by the way Georgia
tied if Georgia really is in play Louis
Trump is done and I know it's important
not to get ahead of ourselves this is
just where the polling stands today if
this is even remotely accurate this is
an insane historic situation we are
facing ourselves with this is just the
result of Donald Trump not being able to
shut up uh he just says stupid thing
after stupid thing and it's destroying
him why can't he just shut up destroying
him and many down ballot Republicans as
well let's not get ahead of ourselves
it's early August we will talk to bill
share about what all of this means a
little bit later in the week